so much for granny shifting  [Laughter]  shifting  cheeky [ __ ]  i'm not supposed to say bridge  this is ludicrous that you want us to  drive across bridges in the presence of  mr bridges no one does that  you see yourself as a necessary shock to  the system  you know i gotta wait for this aries  project to take power from the powerful  it's sort of a regeneration system think  of the brakes on a tesla  but different he knows about it he has a  tesla it's the one with the doors  she's not buying she's done it we're  screwed  [Music]  like i'm not gonna just take up  i'm fired it's been a pleasure  i just broke the plane  ladies  i'm calling myself  it's like letty get you together  who's dominic toretta oh he's the guy  that owns the donder dealership who's  dominic toretto he's number one on the  call sheet sir  who's dominic toretto whose movie you're  in  [Music]  [Laughter]  he's bloody furious  and he's quite fast too  [Music]  you